thanks everybody for coming out today so
my name is Adam for those of you who I
have not gotten to meet in person and
yeah I don't know what the title of my
talk would be other than things I've
learned about CSS over like ten years of
typing it sometimes so when I went to
college this was one of my cool alright
this was one of my favorite quotes and
my chemistry professor gave this to me
to kind of make us less afraid of
learning and trying to break down things
that already existed and I think that
this is really true in the world of
front-end development because it's
really really a very baby discipline
hasn't the internet hasn't been around
that long chemistry has been around
forever right and we're still learning
about chemistry constantly so I think
that it's really important to remember
even if you've only been typing CSS for
a couple of months that there's a lot of
work to do there's a lot of stuff that's
broken there's a lot of stuff that's not
fun about typing CSS or front-end
development right now in general so yeah
I try to keep that in mind that it's
part of our responsibility to fix it a
little bit so a quick couple things
about me I come from this state which is
in Maine it's very cold there home of
the Maine cat if you're unfamiliar
it's a pretty majestic beast I'm a
definitely a big cat fan if you did not
know I went to college in Ohio
another cold cold place and I studied
studio art there and then I moved to
this wonderful state of California
places much further south called Los
Angeles because I got a job designing
amusement parks which most people think
is like this but I didn't get to design
any rollercoasters at all that's smart
people who do physics and engineering
and things like that but they did let me
color pictures in of amusement parks
but it was great training as a first
design job because designing amusement
parks is kind of crazy you have all
these things to think about like a
family waiting in line for four hours
for one ride and you don't want to put
the two most popular rides next to each
other because then they're gonna wait
back-to-back you want to spread some
stuff out you've got to tell stories
along the park and you don't know which
direction people are going to go in and
you want the story to make sense the
whole time but the biggest thing I think
oh sorry so I start designing amusement
parks and got a little bored with the
fact that they're still working on
building stuff I was designing eight
years ago and on the web you can build
stuff up in like an afternoon and tear
it down and probably most of the
websites I've ever built don't exist
anymore which I actually kind of think
is cool uh-huh so I went to work for
this company and they called me and they
wanted me to come work on this print
platform where they were going to do
data visualizations of people's energy
usage and mail it to their houses to get
them to use less energy and this sounded
so crazy to me I was like why don't you
make a website and they said we have a
website and nobody goes to it but we
print these reports and we save tons and
tons of energy and that sounded pretty
neat to me I was kind of a dirty hippie
in college and there weren't a lot of
other web jobs where I could save energy
but this platform that I had to work on
the reason I bring this up is it was a
print platform and it was completely
built with HTML and CSS and we had a lot
of problems that didn't exist on the web
like there's no hover States right so
there's no animations there's no
interactive stuff everything's kind of
done in place you can't mess up printing
you can't print something get a mistake
mail it to somebody's house you can fix
your website right and like maybe nobody
noticed when you mail 750,000 or
something to somebody and it's got the
wrong word in it or you know the text is
off the page that's not good for anybody
it's not good for your users and it's
not good for your cuffs
so when I worked at Opower I got to work
with a really talented group of software
engineers that taught me a lot of really
awesome things just about typing code
that helped shape the form of how I
think about authoring CSS so this guy's
name is Dave Copeland he's big in the
Ruby community but one time he
challenged me and he said Adam who do
you think is the best in the world at
CSS and I don't actually think there's
one like CSS Overlord that rules us all
or anything I don't really think there's
one person who's good at CSS but I
understood his question and I gave him
some names about people I thought were
pretty good at CSS and he said what
would it take for you to be the best in
the world and I started to answer that
would be impossible which I realize is
like a horrible attitude to have if you
even though I don't think I could be the
best at CSS in the world I started to
wake up and think like what would it
take like what is there left to learn
like what things can we discover how
would you become the best at CSS and
this guy is absolutely as crazy as this
photo looks this guy's name is yoni and
I was explaining this really convoluted
thing I wanted to build to him one day
and he looks at me and goes dude this is
like so trivial and I was pretty
offended and taken aback because I was
like really complicated I've never done
anything like this it goes but so many
people have I was like yeah I've never
done it and he said you shouldn't be
entertained by doing stuff a million
people have done before he said in
mathematics if somebody's done something
it's trivial and if nobody's ever done
something it's impossible and I'm only
interested in possible tasks and I
thought that like blew my mind right I
was like I'm just trying to get this box
like on a page like your advanced
electrical engineering degree doesn't
apply to me here but I did think it was
a wonderful frame of mind to be and when
we try to approach problems and so I'm
going to talk about this stuff and I'm
starting to talk about some technical
things so I went to work at Salesforce
and we did some business things there I
actually have these slides that order I
went to work here first
so I get here
[Music]
and this is what drives everything
empathy right like CSS is my empathy
medium I know that probably sounds weird
but like I don't care about clean code I
don't care about code in general I'm a
designer
I just want my users to like have a
better life I know that sounds really
freaking silly but like that's my mom
and she's awesome and like I've seen her
use her phone and be frustrated by
trying to use a service and it just
doesn't work and it's like and these are
my grandparents and my grandmother uses
the Internet like all the time
and she calls me to complain about it
and she's like I understand what this
works what browser are using nowadays
but those are people that use the stuff
that we build and I care about their
time I care about their frustration
levels so brings me to this topic of the
veil of ignorance so there's this guy
John Rawls who brings up this concept of
like say you could change anything about
the world we live in right like you
could make completely new systems with
completely new laws what would that look
like
but the the catch is that when you wake
up tomorrow you're not gonna be you like
you might be a woman you might be a man
you might be 105 you might be 12 you
might be really rich you might be really
poor and the point is like to think
about all the stuff you don't have to
think about this veil of ignorance we
live in all the time right and I think
this is true like beyond CSS in our
crazy country right now and I think all
of us live in like so many different
veils of ignorance --is where we don't
think about what other people go through
and I try to think about that at every
level when I write CSS I try to think
about like you might not have a fast
connection and I don't mean some person
in a third world country like have you
gotten lunch at the Ferry Building in
San Francisco like I have like a
brand-new phone I'm like in the building
across from major tech places no
internet cannot get text to load my
phone so like performance matters your
device matters so I try to I try to
embody that I try to think and meditate
on all the stuff that my users are gonna
have to go through and I try to write
CSS that in here
things and doesn't take away from the
experience but as somebody who's written
CSS for like 10 years now this is kind
of how I feel every single day no matter
how much I learn no matter what other
people teach me no matter what cool
frameworks come out so so I worked it
like this
yeah this print platform and I had to
make sure nothing ever broke ever which
was an interesting task and performance
really mattered because it's print and
they've got to rip these PDFs and like I
could make performance changes that
saved like hundreds of thousands of
dollars a year in print costs and I come
to the web and I started asking
questions for these feedback loops I
have on this like wonderful print
platform I say that slightly
sarcastically and I'm asking questions
like well what's better for architecting
your media queries this or this and
people like I don't know and I'm like
well I don't know how much is like too
much CSS for a website like I haven't
built websites in forever I'm people
like I don't I don't really know I'm
probably asking the wrong people I but
if I'd known any of you at the time you
would have given me awesome answers so I
kind of like as I get back to the web I
start really questioning like what is
good CSS I don't really feel like I can
answer that question like that and I
think the first thing is like stuff
works right I for me like I just want
I've only ever been paid to solve two
problems on the Internet which is one
getting people to consume content right
like they might be reading words they
might be watching a video they might be
looking at images but like no matter
what it is like it needs to be on a
canvas right I think if it's off the
canvas they can't solve that problem
with consuming the media and the other
thing is like I need to get people to
type into a box and hit submit
and I'm just trying to not those
two things up right like so I think that
this is important and I think that
there's no bounds to this at all I think
like these watches are probably gonna
break all the websites that I've ever
made but when I start testing on watches
I want it to work there so these are a
couple of things that I believe to be
true and I don't really have much
willingness to compromise them at this
point I think that everything should be
readable on any device and I mean that
like while you're walking down the
street or bouncing up and down in the
back of a cab lawyer slightly tipsy I
mean that like if you're dyslexic you
should still be able to read things we
should think about the typefaces we pick
I think everything should be as
performant as possible like I don't
think the bar is high enough there right
like a thousand milliseconds after that
you're losing money and people's
attention but you're also wasting
people's time and a thousand
milliseconds isn't that long like every
single millisecond counts so when people
say CSS performance doesn't matter I get
really sad I think that designing in the
browser should be easy and we should
have systems that promote that and I
think that doing one thing extremely
well promotes reusability and I know
that that's been said a million times
before but you think about something
like nicholas Gallagher's clearfix class
and it's just this one thing that does
this other thing perfectly and almost
everybody uses it and its canonical at
this point and like we need more of that
we need more small things just just do
one job really well so if I didn't know
better I would think that this quote by
Douglas Adams was about CSS authors at
least the ones I hang out with and write
code with so and I would put myself in
this camp in that I just constantly felt
as I was coming back to the web that I
was doing the same stuff over and over
and over and over again and so I decided
to when I was trying to answer this
question like what is good CSS I was
like you know who might know is like the
top 500 websites so I read all their CSS
and I'm not kidding about that I read it
line by line by line because I was
interested in why systems breakdown
right and CSS is kind of weird that it's
people always tack stuff on at the
bottom so you actually get this linear
view of how systems get up and
and like because I'm empathetic to those
users my first priority is the people
who actually use the products we build
but I also write CSS that I expect other
people to use and so those are my users
and I care about them and this is all I
see this is what I see front-end people
do here's the myth about CSS that
everybody sells you is like do me inline
Styles are horrible
right dude if you run a class you could
change it and it'll propagate everywhere
on your website this sounds like a
nightmare oh my god I don't know if
everybody has a different job than me
but normally I need to change like three
things on one page as quickly as
possible and get the out and like I
don't want stuff to propagate to the
thousands of pages that I can't see if
you've worked on Salesforce as main app
it's not like you can just like run
through and like do some visual
regression testing like they have so
many modules that get embedded
everywhere right and I think that's the
state of development but you constantly
see this which is really just some this
seems like a lot of work to reset margin
padding to me and it seems unlearn able
like I'm not going to remember this the
next time I have a project and I feel
like if I was a cat and I saw that code
I would look like this and and this is
this is another example this is a
different website like I'm lazy I know
you guys don't really know me but I'm
really lazy and it seems like an
incredible amount of work to put ten
pixels of margin on the bottom of an
element yeah this is this is my internal
catalog and like what I'm seeing these
things I'm like you just really want
that Lego block like you want this Lego
block that does margin bottom ten pixels
and this is how I think about building
the majority of UI not all of it
but I think it's really just these like
small Lego blocks that I want to like
throw on HTML really fast so this is
another this person like I would have
left this job I would have gotten like
halfway and man text-align:right got it
yeah so but I start seeing this and like
I asked this question that you know I've
been typing CSS at this point for like
six years and I'm wondering to myself
like like how big is CSS right like I
like so much of CSS you just use one
line things that just like how many
other times using in the system they set
background color to ie right I mean
that's cool and then like look at the
classroom right gray wall
you know like because they're just
trying to change this one thing and like
I don't think this person's bad at CSS
like I think they were trying to do
something that are in a time crunch and
this is their understanding of like how
to traverse the Dom I got nothing but
love for that ah that's my happy cafes
so yes yes this is like 20 kilobytes and
you're probably like what does that mean
and so there's some kind of limits this
ooh so sorry so CSS is like finite for
the most part right like I mean you can
do a bunch of crazy stuff too but it's
not JavaScript it's not Ruby it's not
like open-ended programming thing like
most of what you're trying to do and the
web has already been done before and
like they're just a set amount of string
values so let me give you a good example
here I don't actually know that much
about animations background repeat'
right like these are your only options
so I wondered to myself yeah like if you
just kind of dumped everything into one
file as single purpose classes how big
would that be because I'm looking at
websites like why enjoying Salesforce
they have like a megabyte of CSS and
like that sounds crazy to me but I was I
don't know they've been around 14 years
maybe that's a completely reasonable
amount of CSS to have so when I say 20
kilobytes I mean I have like 140 colors
set to border color right like that I've
never built a website doesn't need of
this many border colors so I tried to
like really blow this experiment out and
put as many possible things in there and
I put a bunch of scales in there but the
point is is like 20 kilobytes that's
minified in gzip by the way that's not
just like a raw uncompressed file but 20
kilobytes is pretty small and it's an
interesting baseline to me and it makes
me look at other websites like
Kickstarter right it has 793 kilobytes
they did this morning anyway that is a
lot and there are two factors there
right like you're sending that file to a
client that somebody's got like download
on their phone or their desktop but you
also are giving all this work for people
to like memorize or sift through later
and so much of it it's just these little
little Lego blocks anyway so that is all
of CSS in one file it's kind of like a
running experiment I have I don't think
that your codebase shouldn't necessarily
look like that was not what I'm saying
at all
but I think I was kind of flabbergasted
that I never asked myself what are the
limits here so that's my happy cat
there's only 20 kilobytes so if you
actually take those single purpose
classes and you wanted to target a
multitude of media breakpoints you could
namespace those classes to only target
three different breakpoints
so you're essentially got the CSS
language times four right I don't know
if you're following me here and that is
only 42 kilobytes or something like that
so this is kind of blew my mind when I
started to put this together and I think
that right now we're starting to see
this move towards more in line style
stuff
I know react there's a talk right now
going on about react where inline styles
are like the future of the Internet and
I could not be more of a proponent of
this I totally think there's a place for
like component based classes and stuff
like that but I think that you know I've
been running these tests on websites and
I don't have the internet right now so I
can't show you my numbers but you know
you can't like 40% of most websites just
breaks down to floats display colors
order styles background colors and
positioning right it's just structure
and skins there's like 40% of your CSS
so I want to give a big thanks to this
guy who has been working on this website
called CSS stats comm with me which is
this little thing that he and I built to
start to try to answer some of these
questions that we were constantly having
like yeah how much is too much CSS when
we refactor a large code base how much
is just redundant like where our biggest
bang for the buck if we want to abstract
things out so check that out if you ever
want to kind of get like a little living
style guide and see what your code base
looks like CSS stats calm this is my
info but I want to leave you with
basically a call to put that back up a
call to arms to like expect
more of ourselves and to push ourselves
more because I think that our users are
important and I think sometimes I've
worked with engineering teams and we're
trying to solve problems and we get away
from the actual problems that we're
trying to solve which is that like we
just want to chip away at making
people's lives better with technology we
want to you know solves problems
creatively but the most important thing
to me is our users and making sure that
like we respect their time so anyway
thank you very much
[Applause]